[Music]
do you love me
i do dumb yes
i do dumb yes just check in sometimes
you need to hear that from a friend you
know
sometimes it's good to hear it from the
horse's mouth yeah wait
that's what they say what does that mean
i don't know because horses don't
they just nay don't they yeah you
wouldn't think you'd get a lot of truth
from a horse do you remember lovely
wonderful
andrew jack who unfortunately passed
away due to
coving yeah a couple years ago he
explained to me the meaning of the word
chunder do you remember that chunder now
you'll have to explain to people because
i don't think they use the word chanda
in the united states of america to
chunder in britain
is to vomit isn't it to chandra to be
violently ill yeah oh i'm gonna chunder
i'm gonna shut down oh
what did andrew jack tell you andrew
jack said that
in maritime in the maritime world
sailing
all that kind of stuff working on boats
when you're in the crow's nest or up
high you would be
fined if you didn't tell people below
that you were going to be sick you would
be fined by
you know your boss and you were supposed
to say watch
out under but obviously as you're just
about to vomit
very very good isn't that great what i
would do when you're up there high
i would just wait till it went to the
one side and you'd be over the water
wouldn't you
and then hold that and hold on
when you did master and commander did
they uh give you an open invitation to
climb the crow's nest
no we did go up though for once did you
yeah there's a scene with
uh me and russell crowe up on and
my character barrett bonding is supposed
to have amazing
eyesight can see things so the captain
russell he says come on up get up and we
went up the top and ours oh i had to
fear done
i don't you know it was all moving and
it was very high up
but obviously before the cameras roll
did they get you up in a very safe
harnessed
no oh no i wouldn't have done it we had
to climb up
and see when you get to the bit that you
stand on
so you climb up i'm doing this visually
even though this is a an audible sort of
uh medium well i'm loving that
but you're climbing up like this right
and then when you get to the bit that
you stand on
the rope goes out the way so you have to
lean back
like bacon you're just like breaking you
lean back
and climb over the thing that you're
standing on
and you have to do that you know maybe
twice or three times as you go up
then the main sale or whatever how
was russell crowe with the heights did
he seem all right he seemed absolutely
just
aussie just like the captain and then
you're next to him thinking i can't
embarrass myself
can't embarrassment losing control your
bowels on the way up do you know what i
did dumb what
i stood near where the the mainsail the
the the mask goes up and i held on tight
piece of rope what they call i think
they call it a suicide grip or something
and i just held on tight so from
from the neck up i looked like barrett
bond and looking into the horizon
but see from the neck down i was a 12
year old boy just hanging on tight
wow lovely story hey let's check in and
see where we're at with uh
a little league of legends update league
of legends
we've still not got that graphic yet
from riot i think they're working on it
they're spending a lot of time and money
on it
all of this promotion that we're doing
for the game how does it go again
league of legends update
sorry if you guys are listening in the
car and that's too loud now last week
i think you very foolishly very full
hardened yeah
yeah said that we were a small melon
for sean sean asked him playing and
we've not heard from him since
john seemed so into it he was like i've
got the set up
i've got the computer i'm ready to go i
just believed him he's very
he's very believable very convincing
sean that's what makes him a great actor
you see
yeah but don't you think and hello and
lots of love to all of our usa
listeners out there don't you think that
there is a thing with usa people where
if you suggest something to them
they'll go yeah i'll do that they don't
want to let people
down do you know what i mean i think
that might be a los angeles thing
i think if you were in like uh minnesota
and you said you want to play uh league
of legends to someone who didn't want to
play
they'd say no absolutely not i don't
know if they speak not from me
no way jose i don't like that stuff
perfect minnesota accent thank you yeah
but just
so we had got to a small garland melon
for sean aston that's what i thought
but can i rethink that are you gonna go
this way
i mean um and don't even think it's a
mandarin
smaller well we've got strawberry seeds
is
nothing and watermelon is top so for
sean
esteem i mean it's a small plum
it's it's smaller for me is it i was so
excited what about a kumquat i come
quiet
i love a kumquat i never know how to eat
them just pop them in your mouth
with the skin on yeah do you wash it
yeah scrub it
yeah i wash all my fruit with uh
liquid soap so even an apple of which i
had four yesterday someone said to me
jokingly have you had an apple today and
i'm counting them and went i've had four
actually
no gallstones for me my friend because
apples
open up the draining valve where gold
stones get stuck
i'll tell you what you might go a bit
higher there dumb go go
go go really up up this is where you go
blender yeah
what your heart yep my god it's it's
uh a very close neighbor to the heart
well i had no idea i would have put it
down here near this kind of
digestive system no you're near stuff
that doesn't doesn't matter down there
you still have your two gallstones which
you've still not made as earrings for
i do have my gold stones but i don't
have my gallbladder i lost that it's
gone
so i tried to hold on to it didn't i
don't but that's for another episode
that's a whole episode to itself when me
and dom
went to north carolina that was the most
the most physically sick i've ever seen
you
i wasn't well you'd lost a ton of weight
i was 125 pounds
but you know how much that is in stone
for our uk listeners it's not a lot
one and a half i think it's about eight
inches
i was worried about you anyway sean
astin kumquat
kumquat elijah wood i mean he's even
he's worse you made me think of a
pomegranate last week it was lovely that
well maybe elijah was a pomegranate
seed that's exactly what he is one
hiding behind one of those yellow
sour bits they're letting us down aren't
they they're both letting us down
although to be fair we've not played
league of legends all week
it doesn't matter the reason for that is
that we're both playing in the same lane
and i'm loving this new character and i
don't want to give away
that lane you got an ace minus i got my
probably my favorite time in
league of legends at the
end of last week i played teemo in the
top lane got an s minus woke up the next
day
played lux in support got an s minus two
in a row
two different champions can you imagine
that could just imagine it with your
brain
i can't imagine getting an s i've never
got one really never
what's the best you've got an a i've
played with you when you've got an a
i've only
i think i've only ever get an a once
well good for you lulu
ah she's great lulu anyway
so elijah sean give us a call
we know you listen to the show yeah get
yourselves on the computer
let's all have fun in the league of
legends
oh emails and real mails fastest tigers
slow as snails
should we get to some uh voicemails
people have got to say to us all right
let's go
johnny boy the pipes the pipes
hey guys ben here from the uk
fantastic work on the podcast absolutely
loving
every minute of it my question is
out of all the movies that have ever
been
if you guys could have been in another
movie potentially together or
individually
what movie would it have been have you
ever sat and watched a movie and going
oh
man i'd have been great for this part
thanks keep up the good work
love from the uk thanks ben lots of love
to you too
that was lovely lovely question here's
what i do dom i'm going to cast me and
you
okay i want to be in the dean martin
jerry lewis movies the road to
wherever yeah and we in fact we should
remake those
yeah we'd be great at those why don't we
do that that's if someone if a studio
head is out there listening and wants to
uh yeah if anyone
if there's a studio head in his private
plane with the radio on listening to the
friendship onion
why don't you remake the road to
london the road to glasgow whatever it
is and we'll make it we'll make you an
absolute
billion dollars love that yeah um
let me think i love those movies yeah
they're great they're very very
light-hearted i mean you and i in new
zealand watched
the apartment and were kind of goofing
off on the idea of a two men
film apartment type thing yeah that'd be
good it's a great film
you and i recently have been kind of
flirting with the idea of doing
a play but another play that i was
thinking
which would be fantastic for us to do
would be glengarry glen ross ah because
we get to scream at each other oh you'd
be screaming at me i think
i think you'd be the guy who really
messes it up and i'd call you dirty
words
i'd love that yeah would you be all
right with that because you can't be
sensitive no about like i like it when
you show him
okay great question ben next
hi billy hi tom my name is starlet
and my question for you is did you ever
keep anything from any of the three
movies
um either a prop from the movie
a piece of costume
absolutely anything i don't know a leaf
from the shire um and if you did were
you allowed to
or was it one of those well like i just
kind of want a souvenir you know
really interested to hear what you have
to say thank you so much
love thanks stella i like how she
finished it love
love i did when we got well i was gonna
say there's a myth
isn't there with a lot of people who are
not
maybe well versed in the acting world
that actors get the chance to just walk
offset with anything that they
feel like it's not like that is it you
have to be
you have to maybe put something forward
and say is there a chance i could keep
this very often i've said to
directors or producers could i take this
with me and say no unfortunately you
can't because we're doing this and that
pete jackson was very generous with us
wasn't he um
we both got our swords both got our
swords
um the back of our chairs with a mary
and pippen don't know where mine is
well i know where mine is good um
our last clapper board for the last
scene so we got some lovely things
feet did you take a pair of feet i did
take some feet i've given them away over
the years i think i don't know if i've i
took a bag of ears
got a bag of these prosthetic ears yeah
of course
um and i got my which i'm sure by the
way you could still do now because i'm
sure it's on file
i got my first day's call sheet in last
days that's brilliant see
you think of things as things are
happening i don't right
it's always when it's done i think i
never got anybody saying
anything but you know that you could
send an email now and say hey guys
could you ask someone to just go back
into the files all they need to do is go
yours is the actual one that's better
yeah it's better i've also got um it was
my birthday once
and viggo gave me a feather
oh really i think he found on this
street
and he says there's a feather and i
thought that's very vegal
i was really hoping for like you know
cash cash or a camera
or something give me a feather that he's
lovely
and talking about vigo are we any
further on uh getting
all of us to be buried together when we
die
you got an email this week but it was
not about death and burial but i could
put that as a ps the next time
if you could i mean i think if we just
get into his brain
and and then he'll start thinking you
know what that would be nice there were
a couple of nice guys nice guys if we
had to
spend the rest of eternity lying with
each other next to each other
with worms yeah then although i think
he'd have you
just a little bit closer to him than me
because you and
vigo share quite a special relationship
yeah you know what i'm talking about we
kissed one yeah you kissed
that's for another show to be honest i
think he kissed you he did very
very violently yeah you enjoyed it yeah
anyway
thanks starlight we'll tell that story
on another episode
of the friendship onion yes billy
yeah magic spoon cereal we love it don't
we it's really
super delicious i like having it in the
morning
but also maybe throughout the day
because it's a healthy
cereal do you know what i've started
doing and this is a bit of fun
if i have a workout rather than having a
protein shake
i have some magic spoon right because it
has
13 to 14 grams of protein in
every serving and only 140 calories a
serving how much sugar dom
let me tell you zero grams of sugar
and also check this out it's keto
friendly gluten free
grain free soy free low cup gmo free
and all the flavors dumb cocoa fruity
frosting and i know that you love
the peanut butter i like to combine the
cocoa with the peanut butter so then you
get a chocolatey peanuty thing oh
so good so go to magicspoon.com to grab
a variety pack
and try it today and be sure to use our
promo code onion at checkout to save
five dollars off your order and magic
spoon is so confident in the product
it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked remember get your next delicious
bowl of
guilt free cereal at magicspoon.com and
use the code onion to save five dollars
off thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode
really you and i have been manscaping up
a storm haven't we we have done have you
been enjoying it getting yourself ready
for the summer
where do you hear this dom i just came
back from vacation and
i noticed weirdly my chest and belly
hair
was getting out of control we're getting
old so i went a bit off script
and i used my manscaper to manscape my
chest
and belly area good everything went well
fantastic
it's very safe they've got guards on the
lawn mower which allows you to uh
just you know shave the hairs on your
body to whatever length you want yeah
and also
when you travel a little switch that
stops it turning on your luggage
and a light very very handy dom
and i never travel as well without my
weed whacker
because i you know shove that up your
nose in your ear
all your unsightly hairs are gone yeah
and it's waterproof so you know you can
use it when you've just got out the
shower type thing
i really like that as well um and also
we got a pair of boxer shorts didn't we
those were great very very comfortable
and you get the crop preserver
deodorant and crop reviver toner
to keep everything in good condition dom
so get 20
off plus free shipping with the code
onion manscaped.com
that's 20 off plus free shipping with
the code onion
at manscape.com tame that summer swamp
in your pants with manscaped
i'm a billion dom my name's connor i'm
from wiltshire england and i have a
question that sort of
branches off from lord of the rings
famously
sean connery was offered the role of
gandalf and ultimately turned it down
saying he didn't understand the script
which fair enough
so i was wondering if there are any
projects not just acting related that
either of you were ever offered that you
decided to reject
and why if you're willing of course fan
of the podcast fan of your work and a
little addition
much like the one ring league of legends
is fundamentally evil and seeks to
corrupt the hearts of men
so please league in moderation
brilliant it can be quite toxic league
of legends it can be i think we've got a
good handle on it
yeah i know that you've stopped shooting
at me as if you're in glen gary glenn
ross
oh my god these headphones are all funny
oh god um well just to touch upon that
for a second didn't your mate russell
crowe
wasn't he not offered aragorn briefly
don't think so
no i think he spoke to me about it yeah
no i never did actually but i did speak
to sean connery about
um the gandalf
i was at dinner with the
the first minister of scotland and they
were
they had a dinner to talk about the arts
and what does scotland need to be
you know more at the forefront of making
movies and stuff
and sean connery uh john
was always you know we need a we need a
film studio which we did
you know sound stages he'd worked in the
greatest movies
all over the world and he knew what
scotland needed
but the first minister did bring up lord
of the rings and i could tell that sean
didn't want to talk about it
because apparently i heard afterwards it
would have been the biggest deal
any actor had ever been offered
by the time because they offered him
points
gross
so just for you guys to know what that
means lots of times
very you know well-to-do successful
actors might get offered
points on the net which is when the
studio have
got all their profits back and now
everyone's in profit you start making
money
when you're really big time you get
points on the gross which is
any money made by the studio at all
yeah because once you're on net
accountants can
always say oh we didn't actually make
any money i can fandangle you
fun dangle it um but in terms of the
actual question have you ever
turned down something or not not read
something and
said no it's not for me and then
um um yeah i
i don't want to say the things that you
know that
that i said no to because then you feel
bad for the person who actually did it
good point there is a couple but there
were always during the lord of rings
time and it was more to do
with well i have to get back to new
zealand
so i yeah it'd be hard to fit in right
you know but without giving them away
did they turn out to be
successful movies that did well yeah
and there's no truth in the fact that
you were going to play
lawrence of arabia and peter o'toole did
a better audition there's no truth in
that
it was all down to his eyes apparently
sparkling eyes
absolutely beautiful one of the most
beautiful
young men ever right so there's some
shots in lawrence of arabia where he
wakes up and the light
is hitting him in such a way in his hair
you just think oh i'd like to buy you a
gin and tonic
it was beautifully lit yeah it was by
the sun i think
and by lights and by lights good old
david lee i'm in the same uh
place as you i'll tell you something
that i didn't turn down
but when i read it my agent said there's
quite a lot of interest in you for this
and when i read it i wrote back to my
agent and said this is a piece of
americana this is like marlboro lights
or coca-cola or a hot dog i think you
need to be
truly from the usa to pull off this
thing and that was
the hangover my agent said it's going to
be a huge film it's probably going to be
a trilogy of films
and they they want to meet you and they
want to talk to you about certain things
in it and i just said
i think this is for usa guys
on a road trip and playing an american
fine but i think
you need to know what it feels like to
be an american bachelor so
it's not for me and was that to be make
tyson yeah
you'd have been wonderful wouldn't it
that's the end of the voicemails but we
do have other questions here guys do you
want to read this one
bill's the first from jackie b jackie b
and frankford
michigan in episode three i noticed
dom's water bottle
had a ton of stickers on it i'd love to
get a tour of the stickers
hear stories about which ones are the
most important
and represent a great experience since
he's such a traveller
i feel there's probably some great
content there i've went very high
thank you jackie b we're doing a little
360 now yes this is one of those
uh water bottles that people drag around
to force them to drink more water to be
honest
the vast majority of the stickers on
here jackie
are fruit because as you know bills
fruit is my all-time favorite food
and i eat a lot of fruit so this is
mainly
tangerine stickers apple stickers banana
stickers
you've got a few other kind of things
like pineapples and
maybe the occasional melon here and
there there's a nice
kind of little buddhist-y
meditation thing anytime i get a sticker
i put it on
and then here's the trick for you guys
at home once you get it covered in
stickers
you then cover it in cello tape so the
stickers
won't fall off in your hands that's very
good is that informative so it's mainly
for
so you could use that when you're trying
to work out how close
elijah is to playing league of legends
with us yeah
yeah not very close at all no an organic
banana
here we go bills you want to read this
one right tiffany stephanie in london
who seems like an absolutely dirty
bugger because wait till you hear this
dumb
who would you snog marry
or kill aragorn gimli and legolas
i bet we'll answer the same way go snog
snog legolas gimli
oh okay we're different mary aragon had
marie aragon yeah of course you would
kill gimli legolas you'd kill orlando
i'd need to yeah he's he's too beautiful
for this world
yeah he's hard to be around doesn't he
when you're that cute yes i can't stop
looking at him yeah
i licked him once we should try and have
him on the show
yeah let's get him on i would love to uh
get into some of
his choices around dogs remember he's
made some quite outrageous dog choices
when we went to that that restaurant the
reel inn on the pch
and he asked the um security guard in
the car park if
the guy would look after his dog and the
guy said no
and he said i'll just leave it in the
car you can just check in on it and the
guy said no
and then all he said all right i'll just
tie up outside the entrance
and then the dogs started freaking out
and attacking
anyone who tried to enter so on the
public address system they had to ask
whoever whoever owns the uh blonde
labrador who's fighting people outside
could you please come get it and at that
point orlando had just got his food and
he said to me you go get it
no i'm not gonna do that you should have
done yeah i probably should have i know
my place
hey dom wait do you hear this number
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss
by the time they are 35.
wow yeah more than 50 million men in the
us suffer from male pattern baldness
and did you know dom there is actually
only two
fda approved medications in the us of a
that can prevent hair loss and guess who
offers both of them i'll tell you
keeps keeps offers a simple stress-free
way to keep your hair
and the great thing is they have this
convenient
virtual doctor consultation and the
medications
that you need will be delivered straight
to your door
every three months and if you're feeling
a little self-conscious about what's
being sent to you in the mail don't
worry the packaging is discreet
and they have proven results keeps in
fact has more
five-star reviews than any of its
competitors that's right dom
and prevention is the key when it comes
to baldness
treatments can take up to four to six
months
to see results so you better act fast if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss
go to k e e p s dot com
slash onion to receive your first month
of treatment
for free that's k e e p s
dot com slash onion to get your first
month free
k e e p s dot com slash onion
hey tom when do you think the best time
is to get
life insurance i don't know i'll tell
you right now is that right
because every year you leave it the
rates can go up
yeah if someone relies on your financial
support whether it's a child
or an aging parent or even a business
partner you need life insurance
to properly provide for your family most
people need 10 times the life insurance
that they get through their employer now
policy genius make it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all in one place why would you compare
i'll tell you
you can save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes
with policy genius you could save 1 300
or more per year on life insurance by
using policy genius
to compare policies that kind of service
has earned policy genius
thousands of five star reviews across
trustpilot and google
getting started is easy first head to
policygenius.com
forward slash onion in minutes you can
work out how much life insurance
coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price
head to policygenius.com forward slash
onion
to get started right now policy genius
when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right layla
would that be layla s layla
from hot springs north carolina if you
had to describe the other as an animal
slash insect what would it be and why is
there an animal
slash insect that you have an irrational
fear of not a respectful
stay out of their way fear of but
ridiculous oh they give me the
heebie-jeebies fear
now just to pull you up on something
here briefly layla
you won't like this bill cause i the
most pedantic i ever get is when we talk
about animals
insects are animals so when you say if
you had to describe yourself as an
animal slash
insect an insect is an animal so you
didn't need to
do a differentiation there no i mean
an animal you to me have always been a
meer cat
i enjoy meerkats they're adorable
and sweet and keen to does in the day
and they're very big on community and
cuddly but they will destroy a scorpion
if they see one
if i need to if i needed to i would
you to me are a lion king of the jungle
i mean it you like your hair it'd be
buff on
oh i do you like do you like keep that
and you know
and i and i like the way you stroll
about no yeah i'll give you like
yeah i really love that and now is there
any animal you have an irrational fear
of
i do have and i know i shouldn't i do
have a bit of a fear
of sharks i'll tell you what it is dom
as an animal there's not much chance of
us being eaten
compared to other animals but as a human
being
i'd a shark could still eat me and i
wouldn't like to be
no be a horrible feeling ah
oh so yeah
um remember when i remember calling you
at one time and saying hey bills we've
got a great opportunity here yeah
we've been invited to fly to south
africa
yeah and free swim with uh great white
sharks
yes you know are they going to pay for
everything let's do it
and you said absolutely not under no
circumstances why would i do that
yeah i've said that to you a couple of
times in your life
another time was bungie he said let's go
bungee and we'll do that and
i said no why it's not it's not even a
discussion
it wasn't yeah why would i jump off
something
yeah i'd know as a friend you're
normally if i present something to you
you normally
even if you're not into it you normally
go yeah well uh
and then there's been a few times when
you're gone no i'm not gonna do that
it's putting me way too close to death
okay but that's better
you were talking earlier about l.a
people and saying
yes but they're not doing that i'm just
saying i know
i prefer it that way for sure so if you
i know you and your son have picked up
re-picked up
for you surfing again your son has just
learned to serve if you
were in the ocean and you saw a glimpse
of a shark would you immediately get out
i don't think i would now i think i
would sit and i would
rationally think about it and think i'm
okay
i don't need this but i wouldn't like to
be
scuba diving and then see one come out
of the darkness
all right i'll give her the fear done
i work with a lovely lady in mozambique
when we were doing wild things we were
looking for
the whale shark the biggest fish in the
world and uh we were swimming with
giant uh rays and obviously whale sharks
at one point
and she's she's been she's a marine
biologist she's been working
under the water scuba diving for 25 30
years and i said so what's the craziest
thing that's happened to you
she said i was at the bottom of the
ocean once not very deep
about 60 70 feet working with a seal
that was just coming down and picking up
rocks and playing with
me playing with the rocks in front of me
and kind of swimming around me and stuff
and she says suddenly it just
disappeared it was with me playing
it was gone like a bat out of hell she
was like what went on there
i couldn't work it out turned around
there's a
massive killer whale in front of her
still about less than six feet
just looking at her like that what's
going on and she just froze like oh my
god
this thing could eat me immediately and
then that thing
disappeared it was there and it was gone
in like half a second
and those things there's no there's been
no documented evidence of it you know
messing you up unless
it's in captivity but it doesn't matter
that would be terrifying
anything bigger than a cod
when you're down there yeah it's quite
scary because it's their world it's not
yours yeah you're at my house yesterday
and we were watching moving art on
netflix and there was some
beautiful footage of wales eating krill
and we were saying that thing has no
interest in eating you whatsoever
in fact if it if it ate you it couldn't
swallow you so it would spit you out
but seeing that come at you from the
deep oh take your breath away it really
wouldn't but you're like but yesterday
when i was at your house
we had to take a picture of ourselves
for a thing and i said
oh i need to put the phone on something
and i saw a white bucket
in your corner and i said can i put the
phone on top of this bucket what's in
your bucket
ends up saying two rattlesnakes there's
not many people
you'll meet in your life when you say
what's in your bucket
and they'll say two rattlesnakes and
there's a little breathing space at the
very top of the bucket and you chose to
put your tripod
one of the legs of the tripod on the
breathing space and as you were
adjusting the leg i
didn't say anything but i was i was
gonna say billy like
where you've got your finger and thumb
if the rattlesnake is there
then you're you know less than a
millimeter away from getting bit
but i just thought i'll just leave that
because we're gonna it's not gonna help
billy
to know that because his hand's there
already that made my thumb tingle
yeah last question here william
about scones a question about scones i
enjoy a scone i do
fastest cake in the world no less scone
hey all right go on bills you want to do
it
michelle from canada says i've visited
england and i've had
authentic scones before
would you say scones or scones i
probably would say scones
okay i think i would say scones as well
yeah
it got me hooked on them now
i can say after dozens of mess-ups i'm
pretty proud of the scones that i make
for friends for gatherings however
this causes a dilemma for me what do i
bring with the scones
do i bring butter or jam f jam which
type
if butter is not a bit of an odd thing
to bring to someone's house
but isn't it even more rude to assume
the horse will be okay with guests
using their butters for the scones that
they have made
she's put she's made some good points
here
can i give you my answers go on please
don i
i would forgo the butter entirely
and if you can get hold of it i would
get clotted cream
for me it's clotted cream and raspberry
jam
and there's a raspberry jam in english
raspberry jam or black currant gem
uh called i think little tips
that's with a pee little tips
uh kind of a slightly sharp you for me i
want a sharp jam
nothing like strawberry juice it's great
but that's too sweet i want something to
kind of offset the
cream cream so i would go black currant
or raspberry jam with clotted cream
which i don't i'm not sure if you can
get all of it in canada you must be able
to yeah i would think so canada's very
uh
uk based isn't it
would you put the cream on first or the
jam on first
cream one side jam the other oh and if
you
had baked the scones going to your
friend's house
would you take both the clotted cream
and the jam
i would because i feel like that's the
whole experience you don't want someone
to
say well i've made you a cake but can
you provide the icing you want to bring
the whole thing so i'd say
fair enough i'm doing the whole scones
extravaganza
do you know yeah i think i think you're
absolutely right there
and i think that would be a better way
to arrive at someone's house but if it
was me and i'd baked the scones
i think i'd just arrive with the scones
and hope that they had something to put
on it
right but then what if you got there and
they said oh we've run out of gym
we've actually not got any butter and
then you've ruined it because the girl
will just have a dry scone
yeah and everybody's there well it's
really dry
it's a good question michelle very good
oh we got a few we've got a few comments
on youtube here
let's read this one from i'm going to
try and get your name right here my
friend
hopefully i don't absolutely ruin it
share
what you reckon bills cher i think that
was very good yeah
shahir said there's a comment on on
youtube please leave your comments on
our on our youtube channel a friendship
on you
and he says being half iranian i really
wasn't expecting iranian cuisine to
reach the show so soon
but i'm overjoyed that it has i'm so
happy you gents enjoyed the
koresh
very good and more still i have to thank
you for this segment of the podcast
though i discovered your gentleman
through the lord of the rings and
believe me i love you guys there
to see you encouragingly diversify
oh wait to see you encouraging diversity
and multicultural cuisine is
heartwarming well
cher we love that part of the world
and we love hearing from you that was
lovely i loved how you tried to make the
last sentence of that much more
difficult than it was
yeah it was quite a quite an easy
sentence but you tried to make it the
most complicated sentence
ever written so guys if there's
anything that you think we would like on
dom and bill eat the world
please send it to us at
the friendship onion at castmedia.com
or speakpipe.com forward slash the
friendship onion and whatever it is if
it's something your grandmother used to
make
in the country that you grew up or
something specific to a town that you
know
please if you have a link to the thing
please stick that in so that we can find
it easier
thank you very much thanks guys look
there's a couple of apple reviews here
bills
is that oh is it i hope it's good once
have a look at this one you read that
one
hey glorian b says
i got my one-year-old dog a bed for his
birthday he now carries it all over the
house and his coziness wherever he goes
listening to your podcast in my earbud
is like carrying
a cozy dog bed around the house that's a
very cool thing and that's another thing
we were talking about earlier on is if
you've now started
a tradition when you listen to bills and
i doing the podcast
whether you listen to it in your garden
or maybe you go over to your
grandparents you're listening to it
together maybe you watch it on a
wednesday night or a friday night with
your pals take a picture
and we'll put it up on our social media
i like that someone said to me they now
sit in the garden they put it on their
speaker they listen to it her and her
boyfriend
with a nice bottle of red wine what
could be nicer dumb
lovely if you do do something like that
please take a screenshot of it and tag
us
at the friendship onion and maybe we'll
feature you here
on the show billy and dom eat the world
now we're moving into my personal
favorite
section of the show but i would just
like to shout out
all the people that recommended that we
do this particular
classic beverage from scotland so thank
you to
janine neal from glasgow nikki
from yorkshire in england obviously kay
from wellington that might be wellington
new zealand or probably another
wellington
and cada from sterling in scotland
who suggested on this week with billion
dollar meet the world
to do billy iron
here comes john with a bottle of iron
here comes john look at him isn't he
magical
wow let's get into it well we can talk
about all the facts but just from a
personal point of view what does iron
brew
mean to you you can use that
bars if you want in your ads i and brew
have some great ads
that's one thing to do very very good
but for me
this is basically the taste of my
childhood
er it used to come probably still does
and uh and a glass bottle
and uh there was always a bottle of iron
brew
me and my friends used to play a lot of
football
soccer and uh there was always a bottle
of iron brew
at the side of the pitch and everybody
would drink the same bottle
oh wow so you get all those spitty bits
in it we called it
floaters oh that's not good so i say you
had some
and you'd say oh dom you've left a
floater
and you don't wanna because by the time
it gets to the bottom no you don't want
that
um the the adverts that i remember
now do you know who did the voice for it
or did it change over the years
oh i don't know the iron brew made in
scotland from
curtis it's gone from gunthers now
a girder do you know the difference
between a beam and a girder
oh do you know i found out i did my
research so a girder
for me is the thing that looks like in
the shape of an h that's used for
building
buildings okay building buildings
building buildings
and a beam a beam is more i would say
a certain shape like a square or a
circle
i mean you you're kind of in the arena
but you're not quite there
do you want me to keep going probably
not i'm not sure if you'll get any
closer
right basically a girder
is a massive beam that's the difference
so a beam would be something that you
might see in a small ceiling
but a girder holds up a bridge or a
building
so made in scotland from gertas means
it's made from
massive pieces of metal which can't be
true and i think a girder would be that
color as well
yeah for anyone who's just what
listening and not watching
it is an orange color it's a violently
orange color
and it just brings me right back to my
childhood
and sharing a bottle with all my friends
it's i was gonna
i was thinking about this earlier on it
was saying that the the taste of iron
brew
is a little bit like a mystery drink but
then i thought well that's the case with
coca-cola coca-cola's a mystery drink
isn't it and dr pepper you don't really
know what that taste is
yeah it's just something it's just
something is this
like a sarsaparilla did you ever have
sarsaparilla when you're a kid i did but
is it different
different isn't it yeah sarsaparilla is
a sort of american thing i would think
is it do you know when the first iron
brew drink was produced
go on 1889.
wow yeah let's read some of these
fascinating
here's one i don't think is listed here
but i'm sure is true
uh there was a thing that came out a few
years ago
saying that i am brew and therefore
scotland is the only country in the
world
where the main soft drink is not made by
coca-cola
right i think that's been people have
said oh that's not true because you know
in north korea but coca-cola's not
allowed in north korea
and the same in cuba but i think what
they were saying
in countries where coca-cola and
coca-cola products are allowed
then scotland is the only one really
because i would clap as the kids say
clap back
i was like yep because i think brazil
might be another example i heard that as
well
which is another thing that we have to
try on the show which is a
a fizzy drink made of a brazilian berry
i think that trumps
i think i think i heard that as well
should we give it a little can we
i'm gonna give it a sniff first because
the smell oh yeah
it does smell like um like break at
school
it smells like that 15-minute break that
you get at school where you drink
fizzy pop and eat coca-cola bottle
sweets oh yeah there's some on my nose
now now
would you drink this in england when you
were growing up yeah we had it in
england
um and it was popular it probably wasn't
as popular as
maybe coca-cola but the other thing in
manchester that was big
and drank by a lot of my friends and was
was huge in my family
was dandelion burdock do you like
dandelion bitter or as the kids used to
when they were kids
dandelion and bird drop but that's like
a strange
spicy no no no he's not having it you
ready
come on can't wait
[Music]
fizzy fizzy fizzy i'm right back to
being 10 years old
i tell you what it's a it's a f
like a very fizzy drink
do see when anyone arrives in scotland
to visit me who's never been in scotland
before
i'll meet them at the train or the
airport wherever it is
excuse me first thing we do fish supper
a couple of pickles in there and then a
hamburger when you say pickles you mean
pickled onions
that was a surprise to me fish chips and
pickled onions on the side
so what would you would you ever bite a
fish and then a little bit of a pickled
onion would you do it on its own
oh so you just make it do your own thing
oh that's crazy
a little bit of pickled onion or chips
and i am brew i mean i like a pickle
don't you
right if you see
a lot of men going to the work will have
the newspaper rolled up back pocket
suit jacket with a botlane brew in it it
says here during the 1930s the drink
gained widespread notoriety from
starring across newspaper scottish
newspapers
in the adventures of barbarou and sandy
do you remember this bill
never heard of that with barbarous
character mirroring sabu from
rajad kipling's uh book that must be
the jungle book the scottish advertising
cartoon was still going strong in the
early 1970s making it the longest
running of its kind
billy connolly was a fan of iron brew he
mentions it
on an album as a great hangover cure it
is a great hangover cure right
everybody has this as a hangover cure
all the sugar in the
uh it's very very good
it contains sodium
benzonate very good for you
as cell acethane
k which is basically medicine
f d and c yellow number six oh number
six the best number
and just as a word of warning yeah
because it isolates this
it does contain phenylalanine
you shouldn't have too much fenila but
that was okay that was okay dom
and this is something even now as we
live in america
me and my wife uh will go to a british
store
and and buy this no matter how much
they're charging
because it's fantastic time not only
that
but you don't care about money because
you've got tons of cash
i wish hey iron brew
is known for its bright orange color and
unique flavor
it includes caffeine which might be one
of the things that helps you with your
cango at kangova
with your hangover a little kick two
controversial
food colorings sunset yellow and ponsu
4re124 you know what i would really like
to do
i've always wanted to do this visit the
factories
around the world that make all of the e
numbers
really what is that process what is it
they come in on a monday morning they
clock in
and they go right you go over there stir
that
you make that hotter you separate that
and by six o'clock this afternoon
we'll have e17 440 four
do you know what i mean yeah i wonder
what it is who knows no one knows what
it is
uh here we go iron brews
trademark application for the brand name
iron brew dates back to
july 1946 when the drink was still off
sale because of wartime regulations
the name changed following the
introduction of new labeling
restrictions
which crack down on a spurious
health claim and intra someone john's
just ruined that he didn't
include the rest of it it used to be
called
iron brew with an o and then they
changed it they took out the o
and it became iron instead of iron
so it's spelled i r n hyphen
b r u iron and it is such a part of my
my childhood dom i can't even tell you
and do you know what we call it like you
know pop
yeah fizzy pop do you know where it's
cold in scotland all those drinks
together
it's not the same as messages right
which we should talk about at some point
coca-cola spray oh can i
can i know this can i guess i think you
know what sherbet no
very close glam ginger
all right you see i'm going to the shops
for a bottle of ginger and i remember
once i went home and i was staying at my
sister's
and i was trying to make a stir-fry i
this is
honestly true i was in tow crossroad and
i went up to the little local shop
and i there wasn't any ginger root you
know in my sister's house
and i ran up and i kind of left the oven
on and stuff so i was running
and i went into the shop and i was
looking i said to the guy oh sorry mate
have you got any ginger
and he said yes all over there mate and
he pointed to the iron broom
and i was like oh of course it's ginger
that's brilliant i love it but why is it
called ginger
was there a gingery fizzy pop at some
point
that was the most popular like the only
ginger beer or a ginger ale
if anyone at home knows why
in scotland we call pop ginger
you should tell the listeners stroke
viewers about the messages story because
that's a very fun
scottish idiosyncrasy yeah you don't get
that one either not really i don't think
anyone gets that
so when we go for the shopping like the
normal shopping eggs
milk bread etc yeah we basics
we go for the messages so if you came to
my house it's made me burp
it is quite burpy iron brush but very
fizzy i get to taste that again double
taste
you came to my house and ally was out my
wife was out
you know at the shops and he says
where's ali
i would say she's getting the messages
right
again do you have any understanding of
the origins of that no
so if anyone at home knows the origins
of why scottish people
call it messages please go ahead my
guess
and this is probably wrong because i'm
normally more wrong than right
but my guess would be back in the day
the corner shop where you did get your
basic
flour eggs water cheese and all that
kind of stuff also
had a little post office section where
you would get your mail
so you'd say i'm just going gonna go
down the shop to get the messages which
also includes your egg flour water
well not water but cheese that's my
guess
so other scottish people would leave you
little notes
a little message like the farmer would
say yeah enjoy my cheese did you enjoy
those eggs
yeah maybe someone will know can we give
it scores right let's give it scores do
you know what the
headlines are dom i do now number one
flavor
flavor
i'm gonna give that an eight
it's high quality flavor it's intense
though
i'm not a big drinker of ginger yeah
bottles of ginger i don't i don't drink
many of them i don't drink coca-cola
but iron brew is
is my childhood dom is it your all-time
favorite
fizzy pop drink out of all the fizzy
pops even
ginger beer everything iron brew because
it's got a history dom
dom man do i hear you i'm giving it a
9.8
wow that's almost maximum scores
aesthetics
wow i mean it doesn't get much cooler
than an orange drink with orange and
blue packaging
for me it's a 9.5
wow dom loves the aesthetics of iron
brew i also love it
the only thing that make it better is if
it was the old classic
glass bottle yeah and whatever the price
was i can't remember say it was 40p
you get 10p on the bottle so you would
drink
it and then when it was empty you could
take the bottle back and say give me
10 p of sweeties now a 10p mixture
mixed bag and you would get some gums
and chelsea whoppers
and oh so what did you give it i'll give
it
a 9.2 just a little lower than me and
then
usefulness it might fall off a cliff
here a little bit
dom good for a hangover hangover sharing
with your friends during the game of
football
could you mix this do they mix it in
scotland do you do like a vodka ryan
brew
or i know most people will be like oh
whiskey
you take it as it is maybe with a block
ice and all that
you got any women in scotland who likes
a little whiskey
whiskey and a hamburger they'll drop a
vine and i don't mind a whiskey
really but if it's not very good whiskey
yeah yeah
what about but in the pubs do they not
do iron brew and vodka or yeah they do
you put i'm brewing any of those any
drink you want so that's useful
what about the lollipops you know um
ice lollies the ones where you can make
them pour iron brew in you've got iron
brew ice lollies yeah you're selling me
you're selling me okay it's jumped up go
on more there's more
a glass a scoop of a vanilla ice cream
iron brew you get a nice drink they'll
titan brew float
you have what about that that's it's
quite versatile it is very versatile
okay well i was gonna give it like a
5.5 but with that in mind
i'm gonna give it a 7.9
for usefulness i could think of a use
for it
every day in my life i'm giving it an
8.9
i'm going to guess that that is the
highest total score of anything that
you've done up to now bills
up to now it has to be dom i'm almost
sweeping
a 10 year old me running around the
football field
thinking oh i can't wait till the van
comes and i'll get a bottle of screaming
the ice cream van kitties was the name
of it right
ding ding ding ding ding oh that sounded
like horror movie
[Music]
mum will get what i am bruncy how was he
ice cream and i am brewing
hey you that's my earphone bar
my guy was called savories and he used
to um do
the teddy bears picnic theme tune it's
true
it's true
anyway guys i will just say this finally
and i'm brew
if you're gonna seek out i'm brew and
you should
which you should and treat yourself to
an iron brew please
please please drink it chilled for god's
sake there's a massive difference
in a freezing cold fizzy pop drink
especially i'm brewed don't you think
room temperature iron brew no yeah and
it's always cold in scotland so we
always got it cold
and then we just to finish off as i look
back
at me as a young man there with her i am
brew
from kitty's van and i would shout
up we lived up in the masonites and i'd
shake up my
mommy throw me down a piece
i would say dom a little bit of money
isn't it no it's a
sandwich and my mum would make me a
sandwich
wrap it up and paper and throw it out
the window nice
that's amazing delicious a piece
love that um well that was i'm brew we
might have peaked
i love that if you guys have any
suggestions for what we should be eating
and drinking and to be fair bills
up to now we've been kind of spoiled
everything that we've done
has been on the upper echelon of
yumminess so if there's something that
might not necessarily be yummy but just
bizarre and worth trying get in touch
let us know where we can find it because
obviously we're in
l.a and it might be difficult for us to
find something if you don't give us a
little link
iron brew made in scotland from gertas
that's very good time
[Music]
hey now we've got some music dom
sorry about that guys my god that was
quite a
noise it came from the very depths of my
soul
i loved it deep deep i think i actually
burped out some pain
oh i just smelt it yeah sorry um hey
on you go this song is from casey who's
in orlando florida
and it's thundercat with the song
them changes is funky
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's what i see i think we're all
hopped up on i'm brew at this point guys
hey um what was gonna say then i loved
it
we've got what a spotify playlist yeah
called the friendship onion you can find
us
our podcast at spotify and then
if you want to listen to all the songs
that we are reviewing to see if they're
funky or not you can find
our friendship onion playlist where
you'll also find this song
and we'll plus we'll send another music
as well yeah
with each passing week we'll put other
songs on there do you know that
reminding me of this is a bit of a deep
go on a deep dive here but do you
remember back in the day
there was an advert for soft mints with
a guy called mr soft who was like
working
won't you tell me why the world in which
you're living
is so strange that reminded me of the
song that might play on that i'll give
you that tom
lovely because the guitar had a sort of
tremolo
and that's a pedal right you play guitar
so what he's doing there is he's just
playing the
normal yeah like chords but the pedal
is it a wah-wah pedal no i don't think
it's a while back i think it's just
banged
on and it's got it's affected
loved it that's fantastic i really liked
it and what i liked about it as well
is i like the repetition i like that he
just says this is what we're doing
yeah i like that there's joy and
repetition yeah princess
join repetition is joining repetition
yeah does join repetition
um uh well from a review point of view
i'm gonna give that
a bootsie collins oh well done high
level of funk
slow funk do you know what i mean if
you're dancing on the dance floor to
that you're not like
totally getting down at a high tempo
it's more like a groove function
i could see you being quite sexy i think
you'd get down low
oh yeah i would i'd go down low you've
got good hips for that
i'm quite happy for a guy i would give
it
a mr strange from the softman i've just
taken
yours no he's very funky and uh yeah
i'll give him a mister strange for that
i like to i'm going to listen to her
whole thing
yeah on the way back casey from orlando
florida
thank you so much for sending in your
suggestion of course
if you guys have a piece of music that
you think is exceptionally funky
that you want us to listen to and review
get in touch the friendship onion at
castmedia.com that's cast with a k
and also you can leave a message at
speakpipe.com forward slash
the friendship onion pow that was the
week in the french
onion and we will see you the following
week
i think that next week we're gonna have
a guest on dom oh really is it a secret
guest are we gonna tell people i don't
know
i think we can probably say it is
you'll probably remember this gentleman
mr richard taylor
or as we know him richard tyler yeah
from weta
from wetter richard taylor is the head
of wetter and there's nothing he doesn't
know about laudra rings
special effects physical special effects
all the masks the weapons all the props
those were the guys i think you could
make a strong argument to say that
weta are the best special effects
company on the planet
i would say yes so if you guys have any
questions that you want us to put
forward
to richard taylor about special effects
let us know and we're gonna have
questions ourselves richard taylor is an
amazing guy please send in your
um questions you'll love it and we will
see you guys
next week toodles all the best
[Music]